don't come guys before the video starts
miss do check out it's a brilliant up
for those who want to pray Salah and
share their wards check them out now
found us a nut Near East under mosque
I'm just heading there now
then keep you guys updated yeah
okay guys I just got here we're gonna go
now
watch this
okay
it's cool
above the sisters has a nap
wallah is in East London mosque while
light has a net is in the mosque what
light has a net is in the mosque
do you know what Hassan that means it
means righteous deed French you guys a
little bit but please listen to me
before you guys switch off here please
listen to me okay guys so oh yeah you're
shocked alright what's number Valley or
a nice town the Masjid boom you're in
Turkey what is going go and have you
lost your mind no I haven't bomb sisters
very simple you want to earn those
Hassim at those righteous deeds were
talking about yes those righteous T's
that's what it stands for easy
I'm here with Montana aid and official
charity that's been running for 30 years
there's the charity number or straight
to their accounts not my account we've
of course expenses etc Nutella expenses
so I want to tell you guys what we're
doing were here for broken Minds kids
who have come from war-torn Syria and
they psychologically destroyed the
pictures that these kids are drawing on
the screen you can see for yourself just
give me another one and a half minute to
two minutes and I'm done I'm gone
inshallah I wouldn't you guys to get
involved do not Laye let the recent
controversy that's been happening
recently to stop you from doing but
these you know wife because you know
he's going so far not you not them who's
me it's coming to whoever it may be but
the people that need it the most
do not let them suffer because of
certain people doing things wrong so
this is we're talking about doing
righteous these brothers and sisters we
need to do something about him right now
a treatment for this child a child here
an orphan child yeah
about 600 pounds we want to help help v
be children orphans to get back to a
normal mental state some of them scream
and shout randomly some of them draw
pictures of war-torn places bombs
dropping on their family members
brothers and sisters how would you feel
if your child was drawing this so we're
gonna go to orphanage after this video
my next video is gonna be us at the
orphanages you're gonna see for yourself
what's happening brothers and sisters so
please get involved besides that I want
to warn you guys inshallah that is close
with everyone be myself
I will be myself as reminder if I say
I'm gonna raise for this fund etc
whatever it may be and I put my account
details there I'll
why do I need to put Mike on detail when
I'm working with the charity why number
two if I come and say oh I'm gonna
there's gonna be some expenses why do I
need to have expenses because sometimes
Shaitaan comes when big numbers come
into your account it's dangerous I do
not recommend anyone to put their own
account details on there
number two is that when you do these
expenses for what you start justifying
yourself oh my gosh I'm so righteous
I'll raise half a million pounds
I deserve maybe just a five-star hotel
and maybe just you know a first-class
ticket on the plane to there and after
just you know I've raised five hundred
shaitaan comes and works in mysterious
ways
or should I say satanic ways so
therefore we don't want no expenses I
don't need no expenses yeah forget that
what I'm saying is very simple
the organization has got me to come here
yes so therefore brothers and sisters
forget his expert if I must do this
prove myself I would have to spend God
knows how much money planning coming
near distributing why do I need to do
that when there is a middleman here
working with one today officially
they've got the connection they've done
all the foundations so that should be an
armed alarm bell if I come and say I'm
gonna have some expenses cut the
nonsense I go to a charity they do it
they've got the groundwork
all I have to do is say here's the money
actually no he's the money the money's
coming to you so our profit sisters
let's get it crackin inshallah let's
prove that no one is going to stop us
from doing righteous deeds and every
single person that donate inshallah
you're gonna get a reward you know what
forget donate invest you invest in your
hair after thank you for watching
forgive me from pranking you guys but I
had to I had to yeah I'm the I'm the
king of clickbait good bye Salaam
alaikum
hello koala sisters jokes aside now a
lot of you guys are attuned you know I'm
a gosh you found has an ADD he found us
an IDs I found us a not in the Masjid
you can find has a net in righteous
deeds' you can find has a net in obeying
your mom you can find has a nut in
giving zakah go in Hajj being kind to
your spouse whatever it may be so since
you guys are just guests and you know
you're just you tuned in just so you can
sorry go two minutes to it so yeah so
since you guys are so indulged in this
and you've actually for I found him you
should have got nothing better than to
chase this guy yeah so what wouldn't say
to you guys inshallah is that righteous
these are in the Masjid in your Salah
and zakah in Hajj you know being allah
subhanaw taala so i just wanted to share
that reminder of you guys insha'Allah
and I specifically thought to myself you
know this needs to be done you know why
I love you guys a to nurture gossipping
let's see if he's found me etc yes I
found has a net in the Masjid so go to
the Masjid previous our pretty sure
inshallah and look for her Senate
they're not in the actual asset anyways
hope you guys benefited and forgive me
if I have pranked you guys